nuevos vientos soplan entre méxico y
eeuu
el presidente joe biden lleva muy pocos
días en la casa blanca y ya ha avanzado
en la supresión de varias políticas que
tensaron las relaciones con su vecino
del sur durante la era trump en este
periodo optó por proteger el estatus de
jóvenes indocumentados que llegaron
ilegalmente al territorio estadounidense
cuando eran niños suspender la orden que
obligaba a los solicitantes de asilo a
permanecer en mexico y detener la
construcción del muro en la frontera
entre ambos países con el que el ex
mandatario dijo que frenaría el crimen
que cruza desde mexico un proyecto que
fue emblemático y que lo impulsó desde
el inicio de su campaña
lópez obrador celebró la decisión de
frenar el levantamiento de la barrera
fronteriza la migración siendo un tema
espinoso entre los países obligó a
méxico a adoptar estrictas medidas para
detener el gran flujo de personas que
entraban a su territorio buscando llegar
a eeuu pero pese a la presión sus
líderes lograron acercamientos que se
espera sean más significativos durante
la era de bailén primero
agradecí
su decisión de llevar a cabo una
política
migratoria
que incluye
reconocer la ciudadanía estadounidense
a millones de mexicanos que viven y
trabajan en eeuu
el presidente mexicano fue el primer
mandatario de américa latina en
establecer una comunicación directa con
biden como jefe de estado por medio de
una llamada telefónica abordaron otros
temas como la pandemia de kobe 19 y la
cooperación para el desarrollo de ambos
países
lópez obrador ha dicho en más de una
ocasión que coincide con los
planteamientos del líder demócrata
especialmente en materia migratoria y
dejó claro que quienes quieren ver a
estados unidos y méjico enfrentados se
van a quedar con las ganas